weird well yours is - wow it's not quite
where yours is that I've seen where it
can get I've seen a quiet yes nothing
where this leads Oh what happens you see
where this goes perfect sound effect
yeah to be used later yeah well me I'm
just peed through yeah
well congratulations 2018 has been a
it's pretty wild
it's a pretty wild to your yeah totally
what are you attributing this success to
this year what it's been it's fantastic
thank you very much I have no idea it's
uh it's pretty overwhelming I mean the
the movie was honestly you know
definitely one of the most incredible
and special experiences of my life
yeah the fact that it was such an
intimate special process with my wife is
I don't think there will ever be another
one like it you know so and then to have
this come right after I've in the same
years just I mean I think it's
scheduling partly yeah I didn't I didn't
expect it yeah that's fantastic I mean
to follow up a quiet place with Jack
Ryan this is a great show I want you to
smile it and I want to watch more thank
you very much that's awesome why did you
want to sign on for this show what made
you excited about doing this well it's
something that you know I've always
loved the character I mean ever since I
was a kid I definitely you know watched
all the movies read all the books and I
think that that's definitely part of it
the opportunity to play this character
is really the reason to sign on and then
I think that pitch from the showrunners
was you know this long-form storytelling
that I think is really particularly
helpful for Jack Ryan you know I think
the the pitch to them from them was
maybe movies isn't the best medium for
Jack Ryan because it's so much to jam
into two hours and Clancy's books or so
you know they're they're long and
they're super dense and they're they're
they're you know they have they're rich
with character and detail which we get
to explore in this yeah that's what I
kind of love about this is that there
isn't just a quick you know beginning
middle and end we're gonna have time to
actually go deeper into like
exaggerator's exactly show what did what
do you love about Jack what makes you
love playing him I mean for me I think
it's really cool you know maybe it was
this love that I had for him as a kid -
is the same reasons I mean is I think
that he's a regular guy you know I mean
he doesn't have a cape he doesn't fly he
really just uses his brains and his
instincts and so I'm sure even as a kid
I said the words maybe I could be Jack
Ryan so I think that that's really
exciting I think someone with a real
moral compass is really interesting to
play I think that one of the coolest
parts about this season is someone who
has such a moral compass who's trying to
do the right thing realizing how
difficult it is to do the right thing
all the time and that you know certainly
in these geopolitical complicated
situations it's hard to do just one
right thing it's a where are you gonna
sacrifice where are you going - can you
withstand being the the good moral
person in the room yeah and I mean he is
a regular guy and these are real people
there are you know there's real people
who have these jobs which are
exceptional jobs yeah like kind of blow
my mind totally like I'm sitting here
right now talking to you and I'm like
all right this is cool but like what
they're doing really matters no it's
huge and that was one of the best parts
about certainly preparing for the role
was meeting everybody at the CIA we
actually went to the CIA which again as
a kid that's all I ever wanted to do is
finally one day get there and you know
to actually go in there and not only
meet all these incredible people who
were so diverse so open and generous
with their information which I was not
expecting I thought it would be the most
boring interview ever because they're
not allowed to talk about anything and
it turns out they were super open about
their process and what they go through
as as officers and and and more than
that even talking about how it affects
them personally how it affects their
families how it affects their marriages
their kids it was really it was really
wonderful and what you do realize
exactly what you said which is these are
men and women who have dedicated their
lives you know I mean and it's also very
apolitical at the CIA they're they're
not in it for any political gain or for
any one side they're in there just for
this much more generalized in my venue
much more important version of the
country which is just why we're all so
proud of where we're from and and
they're very proud of what they do and
they should be and so it's it's a real
honor for me to to bring even a lighter
version of what they do to the screen
I'm super curious to kind of find out
the themes that are going to be explored
I noticed in the pilot there was some
flashbacks hop
and I mean mental health right now is
such a sensitive subject that you know
I've had to deal with friends that have
such situations yes yeah are we gonna
explore something like PTSD a bit more
yeah yes absolutely there's you know
PTSD is a very important thing I think
that we obviously cover lightly because
it's a television show I'm in lightly
meaning we don't handle it lightly
there's there's not a ton of it in there
but I think it's a really important part
of what makes Jack Ryan who he is in the
show where he's coming from and why he's
doing what he's doing and also gives you
insight as to why he might have joined
the CIA cuz he went to Wall Street after
after the Academy and after his service
time and and and you realized that
there's always been a hankering for him
to get back in the field obviously I'm
gonna ask this because you did such a
fantastic job with a quiet place to you
I have to direct any episodes of Jack
Ryan is that maybe no I never even
really thought of it again it's I had
the luxury of just being the actor on
this show you know um I definitely have
my own world that I love writing and
directing and producing my own stuff and
I get really really excited about it and
this is very much a Carlton Lynne Graham
show the direction that they're taking
and what they want to do with it so yeah
I'm sort of I'm sort of digging just
being the actor on this and then you
know preserving all my directing and
writing stuff for my own my own thing
that's awesome is something else that's
great is there's already a second season
yeah this has not even aired yet and the
second season it's crazy right pretty
incredible and it's you know good on
Amazon to take a shot like that it's
really cool and you know obviously we
feel very lucky and supported that they
would want to do that but yeah I come
from the office where we were gonna be
cancelled the first two seasons like
every week and so I never I never look
forward and say like yeah this may or
may not get picked up so the fact that
we have another season is awesome when
we're about to shoot it in three weeks
we're going down to Colombia and we'll
be exploring the South American politics
in Venezuela and thing like that yeah so
it's really fun the locations that this
was shot and was shot in Montreal it was
shot dubai did you actually shoot and do
both I didn't go to Dubai no I was in
Morocco here Morocco for a long time we
were in Montreal for a long time I were
in DC Paris I mean
and being an actor is definitely a
lottery ticket life it's a fantasy camp
and I'm just so overwhelmed lucky to be
here but one of the best sides of it is
that you get to travel for work I've
never traveled like this for work I mean
I think for 13 hours we went to Morocco
for like a week but yet to have the
opportunity to travel around the world
and immerse yourself in these cultures
is is amazing I loved it you mentioned
the office so I'll probably get killed
by my co-workers very huge fans if I
don't ask but will there be a reboot is
there talk doesn't mean anything it
sounds like there's been talk I just no
one's been talking to me so either that
means NBC doesn't want to do a reboot or
they don't want me either one is uh is
that I think they probably want a reboot
it's just hard to schedule everybody
around but you did say something smart
they're like how confident you were with
it let you're like this and this is
what's happening over at M yeah thank
you feel better well they're definitely
watching I know that right it's just you
know scheduling conflicts when talking
to them having maybe a little bit I was
down there last week I would love to
know why would you tell people they
should tune in to Jack Ryan what do you
think people are gonna get from watching
this series I mean there's a ton that
you get from watching this series I
think that this is a you know a very
heroic character that like I said is a
real person he's not a superhero and to
me that's really refreshing to celebrate
our real heroes especially the men and
women who are in the military or in
these services so I think there's that
but I also think it's a lot of fun I
think that what distinguishes this show
from say homeland or any of these other
sort of spy genre things is home lands
about an antihero homeland is really
dark and really intense which is awesome
I love that show and I love what Claire
does with it and this is definitely you
know Graham and Carlton want to do the
more commercial more sort of
over-the-top big movie version of it and
so it's it's kind of like watching a big
movie on television well anyone who's
missing the office I kind of feel it
felt like watching this it was you know
Jim jacked and like hipster that seemed
riding the bus it was wicked great you
mentioned working with your wife Emily
quiet place too that's gonna happen
eventually yeah I mean paramount
announced it so I guess it has to happen
but
I actually will commend them too for
being so supportive of making sure we
find a really good idea to do a quiet
place to so that it doesn't just feel
like we rushed into it because it was
successful and I'm sure that is one of
the reasons I want to do it but it's
also you know they're really cool about
letting us find the right way and my
only concern and and the only thing I
care about is making sure it's good
enough for the people who saw the first
one in love the first one I don't want
to let him down
of course yeah and you two working
together on-screen was just thank you it
was so good I loved I can't imagine
working with my partner like that it's
such no it was definitely the best
experience my entire career she is
without a doubt my she's always been my
favorite actress but to now she's my
favorite collaborator she is she's an
all-star and everything she does she's
fantastic and so is this show so Kay
really appreciate you doing this thanks
man take care thanks